[Music]
the fighting in Sudan that spilled into
a fifth day despite a ceasefire as
taking a heavy toll on medical
facilities hospitals have been destroyed
people can't access doctors ambulances
can't move safely and basic drugs are
hard to find Sudan's Health Ministry
says 16 hospitals have been forced to
close in Khartoum State it's warning the
number is likely to rise the Sudanese
doctors Syndicate says 39 out of 59
basic hospitals in the capital and other
conflict-affected areas are now shut
some clinics have been bombed While
others have closed due to a lack of
supplies Sudan's doctor's committee says
it's struggling to treat the injured
with the escalation of violence and
security tensions the doctors had to
evacuate all the cases except the cases
inside the Intensive Care units there is
a shortage in staff medicine and oxygen
the hospital is witnessing a shortage in
many things even the doctors we have
left
Fareed Abdul khadir is the head of the
Red Cross Country program in Sudan he
says that the organization has not been
able to provide humanitarian assistance
because of the fighting
at the moment it is almost impossible to
provide any humanitarian services in and
around hartum they are calls from
various organizations and people trapped
asking for evacuation for the past four
days people have been out of water food
electricity has been rationed in some
places totally disconnected so we're
talking about a situation where there
has been calls to the Sudanese requests
and then also to the International Red
Cross movement their presence in Sudan
almost on a daily basis from people
wanting basic humanitarian Services uh
this will not be possible until uh
Assurance for safety uh of the
volunteers we have thousands of
volunteers who are ready able and
trained to perform humanitarian Services
unfortunately due to the current
situation they are not able to move we
have ambulances we have uh people who
are able to provide Cyprus I mean the
first day the psychosocial support but
that will only be possible once that
humanitarian Corridor is assured by all
parties
okay let's go live now to hibber Morgan
in Khartoum yeah but we'll get a an
update on the Damage Done to the health
infrastructure in just a moment but
first can you just bring us up to date
with a fighting there this morning has
the ceasefire been basically completely
ignored
thank you
yes that's very much the case from the
very first minutes of when the ceasefire
was supposed to come into effect we were
able to hear heavy artillery and heavy
shelling around the vicinity of the
presidential Palace around the vicinity
of the general command of the army those
are the scenes of intense fighting over
the past few days in fact since the
start of the fighting between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army and
even now on the fifth day of the
fighting we can still hear the sounds of
heavy artillery at the sounds of a
shelling it's not clear who is shelling
it who exactly because it's not clear to
for for many people here to get a sense
of who has the upper hand but the
Sudanese Army did release a statement in
the early hours of this morning saying
that there is fighting ongoing around
the vicinity of the general command of
the army they say that the rapid support
forces once again try to attack the
general command and that they are
repulsing those attacks and were able to
strike many of the vehicles of the rapid
support forces the air report another
scene of heavy fighting and bombardments
there has been another airstrike there's
been another strike it's not clear if
it's an airstrike or just heavy shelling
at the airport a fuel storage Depot has
been hit with heavy heavy smoke coming
out from those vicinities the vicinitys
of the uh of the general command of the
Army and the airport so it's clear that
despite that this is supposed to be a
period where there's a ceasefire and the
two sides giving the chance for
civilians to evacuate or seek basic
necessities that is not happening and
fighting is still ongoing yeah this is
of course having a massive impact on the
health facilities there can you just
give us an idea of just how dire it is
for the doctors and nurses there
yeah
well from the very first day of the
fighting on Saturday there has been
concerns about the health facilities
because many people were not able to
leave their homes to be able to seek
medical assistance and those who were
able to get to the hospitals were not
able to find enough medical staff and
medicines to attend to their medical
needs now over the past few days there
have been many hospitals dozens of
hospitals that have been destroyed by
shellings and and many and some
hospitals that have been raided as per
doctors and being used as bases for
operations by armed groups so the
situation the medical situation is quite
dire there is one Hospital which uh in
the late hours of Tuesday put out a
statement saying that that they were
partially damaged by heavy shelling
that's Al Fidel Hospital not very far
from the vicinity of the general command
of the army and they said that they had
to evacuate many of their patients
accept those in intensive care units
because those cannot be uh evacuated
they say that there's a shortage of fuel
and they're operating using generators
but that there's a shortage of
electricity they're operating using
generators but that may run out of fuel
soon and they would need some backup but
that is not going to be possible because
of the ongoing fighting there are also
shortage of medical staff and medicines
in those medical facilities and then
they're the patients who are already
trapped at home and able to seek a
hospital Assistance or medical
assistance so the situation the
humanitarian situation and the medical
situation is quite dire as fighting goes
on between the two sides and as more and
more people keep getting injured okay
thank you so much that is Heber Morgan
for us and hard term
well for many people in Sudan social
media has been the main source of
information so the hardat has more on
what's being shared online
despite the constant internet
Interruption some doctors have managed
to post videos online and the situation
there they're saying is dire they appear
to show bodies lying in the emergency
room at al-jalda hospital in hartum now
the doctor that's speaking in this video
speaking in Arabic and you can hear it
in his voice he's shocked staff are
overwhelmed the number of casualties is
rising and medical supplies are running
very low fast now many doctors nurses
and patients remain trapped in medical
facilities across the country incredible
scenes that we've been seeing in some of
these videos where staff from a dialysis
center in the capital of able to make a
lucky Escape patients were wheeled out
under heavy gunfire some can be seen
even to be wearing Hospital blankets to
keep them warm now also in the capital
88 students and their professors are
still trapped in the University of
Gordon since the fighting started on
Saturday now they've turned to social
media to call for help
hello there captured the situation is
really scary fighting has started again
and it's continuous this evening one of
our students was killed we haven't been
able to bury him yet another student is
critically injured we need rescuing we
have run out of food we are really
scared we are scared we will also run
out of electricity and water
now the area where the university is
located has seen some of the fiercest
gun battles let's take a listen
now students on Monday try to escape
from the campuses Library that's where
graduate student
was shot and killed now he's since been
buried by his friends and fellow
students on campus but the rest of the
students and staff still remain trapped
the Army has released a statement saying
it's trying to reach them
[Music]
and for this family I don't know if you
can hear it just in the background but a
terrifying moment captured on camera as
Grandparents tried to comfort kids in
the house they're shelling outside of
their home many have been hiding under
furniture or in other places you can see
there and as far as they can from the
windows now some good news though also
shared by people in Sudan despite the
violence and the chaos video of a newly
born baby was widely circulated on
social media bringing much needed Joys
you can see just there to its family
foreign
[Music]